[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 26 avril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
l'édifice date du 12e siècle l'église
saint-victor de guyancourt s'offre en ce
moment une nouvelle jeunesse
d'importants travaux de restauration
sont réalisés dont les prémices
remontent à il ya 20 ans le point sur
l'avancée du chantier à suivre la loisy
les migrations a été adopté il ya
quelques jours en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale un texte qui a
suscité beaucoup de débats et pour la
première fois au sein même de la
majorité de la république en marche
comment ont voté les députés yvelinois
du parti présidentiel a répond sans
tronic
enfin direction le parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse de
petits explorateurs sont allés à la
rencontre des habitants des marques
une animation proposée par le pnr pour
sensibiliser sur la faune et la flore du
territoire elle nous recevons également
à tout à l'heure de représentante de
l'association diaspora elle raconte
l'histoire de l'exclavage à tous les
publics c'est à suivre dans ce journal
est des travaux sont donc en cours à
l'église saint victor de guyancourt
c'est la dernière phase de la
restauration de l'édifice datant du
xiième siècle
elle a débuté ses travaux ont débuté le
5 mars dernier et devrait se terminer
courant air reportage de nicolas landry
bientôt la fin de vingt ans de
restauration des travaux pour redonner
une jeunesse à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt la dernière phase concerne la
toiture du bas côté de l'édifice datant
du xiième siècle une intervention menée
par un cabinet d'architecturé spécialisé
dans le patrimoine historique
la pente est temps
inférieure ou au pourcentage de mise en
oeuvre de la tuile plate traditionnelle
qu'on met en oeuvre actuellement on
était obligé de réaliser une sous
toiture en zinc c'est les travaux
d'étanchéité de la toiture puisqu'il y
avait des infiltrations d'eau est
maintenant à ce jour on a réalisé
l'ensemble de la toiture
oui ça veut dire que sauf accident
particulier on va être tranquille pour
une période voit un siècle voir aussi
avec l'ennemi l'église saint victor a
connu une longue cure de rajeunissement
de son intérieur l'installation du
chauffage à la toiture et au parvis
devant le bâtiment
l'investissement total de la ville
avoisine les 1,5 million d'euros il
fallait faire toute façon comme c'est un
monument historique veulent absolument
que la ville s'engage à restaurer
l'église
l'important c'est de voir avant et après
est ce que cela attire beaucoup de
personnes pour venir à cette église
c'est quand même une église qui est du
moyen âge qui est à deux cols du 12e
siècle
allez pour ceux déjà qu'ils font là qui
suivent le cul et puis il ya aussi le
fait je vous dis sympa à bâtiments
importants quand même les bâtisses
historiques un domaine important pour la
commune chaque année la ville engage
600000 euros dans son budget pour
l'entretien du patrimoine 999
amendements discutés soixante et une
heure de débats le projet de loi asile
et immigration a été adoptée en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale est 2
128 députés pour 139 contre le texte a
fait l'objet de vives discussions au
sein même de la majorité bon sens
nicolas kirillovitch bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 parmi les votants ont
bien sûr les députés yvelinois quelle a
été leur vote alors premières
informations déjà il ya douze députés
dans le département des yvelines
trois seulement étaient absents pour
pour ce vote c'est plutôt un bon ratio
comparé à la tendance nationale parmi
parmi les absents on remarque évidemment
la non venue de marie le bec député de
la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription 4e circonscription des
yvelines
michel devaux couleurs du modem qui
appartient elle aussi à la majorité et
michel vial et c'est un peu différent
puisque c'est le seul député
les républicains du département beaucoup
de députés absents ont justifié la non
venue à cause des vacances scolaires
peut-être aussi parce que certains
étaient gênés d'afficher leurs
convictions leurs positions réserves par
rapport à ce texte vous en parliez
nicolas il ya des parlementaires qui
n'ont pas souhaité voté pour ce texte
c'est le cas notamment d'une députée
vaudoise
oui il s'agit de florence grange du
député de la 12e circonscription des
yvelines membres de la république en
marche et qui fait donc partie des
abstentionnistes sur ce texte
ils ne sont que 14 parmi les 12 212
votants de la majorité florence granger
ancienne directrice d'une agence pôle
emploi s'est notamment opposé au
placement des mineurs en centre de
rétention elle s'est exprimée d'ailleurs
sur le sujet samedi à l'assemblée on les
écoute
la france fait partie des trois pays
européens qui ont pas se placer le plus
grand nombre de mineurs en rétention
administrative
alors même que de nombreuses solutions
alternatives à l'enfermement existe il
n'est pas possible de construire un seul
être un seul pays et une europe forte
avec pour exemple dans les yeux
d'enfants qui seront aussi les femmes et
les hommes du monde de demain des
barrières appréhendé dès le plus jeune
âge
trois députés asie blinoise sans florent
grand jeu qui s'abstient qu'en est il
des autres parlementaires nicolas vous
allez le voir sur l'écran l'ensemble des
autres députés ont voté pour ce texte en
première lecture que ce soit les élus de
la république en marche ou du modem ils
sont huit au total
à noter pour l'anecdote ce qu aurore
bergé didier baichère n'ont pas été
enregistrés officiellement parmi les
pour à cause d'un problème technique à
l'assemblée au moment du vote mais ils
sont ils ont soutenu largement ce texte
un texte équilibré selon jean-noël
barrot élus modem de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
il en veut pour preuve l'assouplissement
du délit de solidarité on les écoute je
crois qu'un certain nombre d'ajustements
très intéressant et très importants ont
été apportés à cette loi par l'assemblée
je pense notamment à
à la fin du délit de solidarité
désormais lorsque des personnes et
escorte dans leurs véhicules des
personnes en détresse vers un hôpital
par exemple elles ne pourront plus être
inquiété alors ya une question qui
demeure tout de même nicolas à propos
d'un éventuel début de fracture au sein
de la majorité est ce le retour des
frondeurs version en marche en effet
c'est la première fois qu'un texte est
autant débattu au sein de la majorité
qu'autant de craintes et réticences sont
exprimées par les députés depuis un an
rien d'affolant cependant pour nadia et
député de la 11e circonscription est des
yvelines pour c'est normal finalement
qu'il y ait des divergences sur un tel
sujet effectivement il y avait un vrai
départ parfois discussion un peu un peu
musclée au sein de la majorité parce que
nous avons des personnes de conviction
parce que nous avons des personnes qui
sont engagées depuis des années sur ces
sujets là et évidemment ils expriment
leur point de vue qui qui forcément ne
ne va pas de prendre d'autres
d'autres députés de la majorité
on ne peut donc pas parler pour le
moment de fronde comme au temps de
françois hollande mais des avis qui
s'expriment simplement dans un débat
démocratique on verra malgré tout si ce
sera toujours le cas après le vote du
sénat en juin le texte sera sûrement
amendée par la droite et les discussions
devrait alors reprendre ardemment au
sein de la majorité de la république aux
mains merci nicolas pour ces précisions
à la fin de notre dossier à présent
dossier de la semaine sur les 50 ans de
mai 68 pour ce dernier opus regard
croisé entre un représentant d'un
syndicat étudiant et un universitaire et
notamment sur le lien de mai 68 avec les
mobilisations actuelles de la sncf et
des étudiants un entretien préparé par
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
kirillovitch
[Musique]
pour l'université ça permet une période
de libéralisation on a décidé de changer
un peu des méthodes archaïques qui
étaient en cours à l'université sur
l'érection des libération des moeurs
aussi ça a permis d'enclencher ce qu'on
a appelé la révolution sexuelle aussi
sur la question sociale
mai 68 c'est des acquis sociaux
augmentation des salaires amélioreront
des conditions de travail donc même si
ça reste lointain mai 68 c'est quand
même pas mal d'haïti et qui ne juge pas
encore aujourd'hui en fait je pense
qu'il faut prendre en compte une
séquence plus longue qu'on appelle
désormais les années 68 qui prennent
racine dans les années 60 et qui
s'étendent jusque dans les années 70
et là c'est vraiment un moment charnière
dans l'histoire française avec
d'intenses transformations politiques
sociales et culturelles
[Musique]
je pensais un peu des deux on commence
beaucoup mai 68 est extrêmement renoncé
il ya un peu un mythe révolutionnaire au
tour régulièrement dit voilà enfermé 68
c'est pas mal ce qui est en cours
actuellement nous il ya beaucoup de
mythes
c'est sûr on vendange beaucoup mais ils
sont aussi une réalité et ça a été un
fort mouvement et si c'est justement si
on en parle comme un mythe c'est parce
qu'il a marqué des générations et des
générations et que l'on tente même si le
contexte est différent de recréer un
mouvement d'ampleur équivalente alors
c'est vrai que mai 68 avec une majuscule
dans lequel on oublie le mois de juin et
puis cette séquence plus honte de
contestation est devenue un mythe
au fil des années des contestations des
discours un peu stéréotypé sûr sur cette
époque
néanmoins on a quelque chose qui est
quand même assez extraordinaire dans
l'histoire ne serait ce que par
l'ampleur de la contestation dans
évidemment les universités mais aussi
dans le monde du travail
[Musique]
l'idée ce n'est pas de refaire un mai 68
c'est ce qu'ils n'essaient pas refaire
la même chose par le passé par contre
oui clairement aujourd'hui comme en mai
68 on se rend compte que étudiants
salariés ont sur l'instant de l'attak
nous c'est la mise en place de la
section en retraite de l'université
c'est la fin de nos droits comme le
rattrapage la compensation et nous ce
qu'on veut c'est à faire converger les
luttes qui est le plus de nominations
possibles et qu'on arrive à faire pis
gouvernement alors évidemment il ya des
effets de résonance parce que parcours
succès une mobilisation qui contestent
la sélection à l'université et que
c'était déjà à l'ordre du jour de la
réforme de l'université en 68 et c'était
déjà contesté à ce moment là donc
effectivement il ya des effets de
résonance mais aussi ce qu'on retrouve
comme élément de comparaison c'est que
on a des mobilisations qui se font dans
différents milieux sociaux est la
journée nationale des mémoires de la
traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions a lieu tous les ans le 10 mai
plusieurs associations du territoire
parle du sujet comme à bois d'arcy où la
diaspora raconte l'histoire de
l'esclavagé à tous les publics avec moi
pour en parler d'eux invité sur ce
plateau eliane félicité bonsoir bonsoir
êtes la présidente de la diaspora et
vous êtes venu avec mélanie lebris
bonsoir vous êtes étudiante en bts
économie sociale et familiale et
familiale alors dans le cadre de vos
études vous avez rejoint l'association à
la diaspora vous allez nous dire
pourquoi et pourquoi vous êtes
intéressés par cette thématique ça sera
dans un instant déjà peut-être un mot
sur l'histoire de la diaspora
eliane se félicite elle raconte donc
l'histoire de l'esclavagé aux 7 77 ans
pourquoi créer cette association
alors l'association a été créée parce
que elle va amener les les caribéens
essentiellement à retrouver leur
identité perdue donc et de plus
je souhaite
avec les difficultés climatiques qui
existent plutôt que de faire des
associations ponctuelles faire une
association durables et efficaces pour
aider la population à se construire en
faites vous partie des antilles fait
perdu il ya un vrai problème des
caribéens à connaître leur histoire
connaître le rationnement oui alors
l'identité c'est à dire pour se
positionner notamment dans dans la
société
dans cette société qui puisque nous
sommes des départements d'outre-mer donc
se positionner par rapport à la
métropole pour pouvoir exprimer
notamment ceux que l'on peut apporter
dans tous les domaines touristes
social économique et s'est donc retrouvé
son identité pour se reconstruire
vous le diront lisez tout à l'heure elle
raconte l'histoire d esclavage cette
association et c'est à tous les publics
ça s'adresse aussi bien aux jeunes
qu'aux personnes plus âgées
voilà tout à fait de 7 à 77 ans mais
aussi aux européens aux métropolitains
donc les réunionnais enfin tout le monde
est amené à s'y est intéressée à
s'introduire dans cette association pour
vivre ensemble voilà alors mes animaux
collaborer avec cette association dans
le cadre de vos études mais pas que
parce que cette thématique
elle vous tiendrez vous tient à coeur
dans le cadre de mes études évidemment
parce que je suis dans le social
maintenant depuis trois ans j'ai fait un
bac spvl ensuite j'ai continué mes
études en bts esf c'est vrai que
s'impliquer dans une association que ce
soit pour tous les âges mais en d'autant
plus quand on est jeune je trouve ça
important parce que ça montre d'autant
plus les 7 à 77 ans comme disait madame
féliciter et vraiment je trouve ça
important de s'impliquer dans ne deviez
au quotidien et le vivre ensemble ce
texte sans cliquer sur quels projets par
exemple vous avez pu travailler depuis
vous avez rejoint l'association
alors j'ai rejoint l'association très
récemment de vous qu'on a fait avec
madame féliciter les portes ouvertes le
15 dernier et c'est vrai que c'était
assez sympathique on sait quelques
pincées une association très familiale
et du coup on sent tout de suite très
intégrée et c'était vraiment sympathique
alors il ya des actions qui sont mises
en place par l'association notamment des
ateliers
eliane oui alors les ateliers
je peux les citer notamment la couture
alors la pédagogie et de confectionner
une tenue traditionnelle et raconter
l'histoire du tissu c'est à dire comment
les colons les esclaves ont utilisé le
commerce d'où vient ce tissu etc
et quand on a confectionné une tenue on
a une histoire
voilà avec les coiffes les différents
codes vestimentaires les différents
codes de coiffes et à partir de là on
recherche son origine et on connaît son
histoire
l'atelier généalogie aussi un atelier
généalogie tout à fait je suis en
partenariat avec les films les films
graphique
donc c'est une association qui
qui récupère différents documents et qui
peut aller sur cinq générations
donc c'est important pour raconter aussi
son histoire et vous proposer aussi des
rencontres et débats ça va être proposé
oui alors je fais appel aux femmes
d'être là voilà pour les les rappels à
monsieur thuram et madame taubira pour
intervenir dans les différents débats
que nous allons organiser mais pas que
il ya aussi des personnes inconnues
monsieur ramona généticien à l'hôpital
necker
et puis monsieur abdoulaye qui peut
raconter son histoire de sénégal je
précise que vous pouvez joindre
l'association coordonnées qui s'affiche
un bel écran un dernier mot il reste
moins d'une minute les ambitions pour la
diaspora
quelles sont elles alors les ambitions
c'est surtout social économique et
culturel c'est-à-dire sociale ou recréer
des liens parce que il y a beaucoup de
difficultés familiales beaucoup de
familles monoparentales
donc on re qui recrée le dialogue
réinstaurer le dialogue à travers les
différents ateliers que nous proposons
mais aussi économique je souhaite créer
des emplois notamment puisque les
ateliers se termine par des voyages à la
base en afrique mais aussi dans les
caraïbes
et puis culturel donc pour découvrir les
différentes
ateliers que nous proposons notamment
botanique pour apprendre la culture du
travail manuel pas seulement
intellectuelle mais aussi du travail
manuel pour sensibiliser les jeunes au
travail manuel
merci à vous deux et vient de féliciter
présidente et mélanie lebris
collaboratrice de l'association la
diaspora merci d'avoir été avec nous
j'en profite pour préciser qu'une
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé se
tient à partir du 4 mai à saint quentin
en yvelines ou recevront en plateau
d'ailleurs un lundi les organisateurs de
ce rendez vous depuis lundi 62 élèves
des conservatoires de versailles grand
parc répète il participe à la cinquième
édition de l' orchestre symphonique
c'est un concert qui est consacrée cette
année à la musique de scène pour ces
musiciens en r&d grands compositeurs
mélanie poker marion tac ont rencontré
le chef d'orchestre invités de cette
année il s'agit de constantin rui de
l'opéra de massy quand un bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes le chef invité
pour cet orchestre symphonique de
versailles grand parc pourquoi déjà
avoir accepté cette invitation
alors j'ai accepté cette invitation
parce que je trouve que c'est formidable
de réunir des jeunes comme ça autour
d'un stage parce que tous ces jeunes là
c'est des jeunes qui y sont dans des
conservatoires qui ont des enseignements
avec des professeurs de de grand talent
de grande qualité mais c'est des moments
un petit peu particulier pour ces jeunes
de se retrouver
voilà pendant les vacances dans des
dents des plannings qui sont assez
serrés c'est à dire qu'ils sont pendant
toute la semaine les uns sur les autres
et c'est des moments pédagogiques et
artistiques qui sont toujours assez
sympathique et vous dirigez 70 élèves
alors il est des adultes amateurs la
plupart ce sont des jeunes de second
cycle alors absolument c'est des jeunes
qui sont de second cycle avec quelques
adultes puisque vous savez que dans les
conservatoires il ya aussi des adultes
qui suivent des cursus d'amateurs et qui
est qui qui vivent aussi leur passion en
tant qu'adulte et c'est vrai que on a
regroupé donc tous ces élèves de second
cycle donc ils sont d'un niveau à peu
près équivalent les uns des autres pour
pouvoir monter vraiment des programmes
qui leur correspondent au maximum et
c'est un ça qui va conclure une semaine
de stage 6 heures par jour c'est
conséquent alors c'est conséquent et
c'est vrai que c'est on l'aimé beaucoup
à contribution les met à l'épreuve dans
cette affaire et ont donc aujourd'hui
c'est notre première journée de
répétition on a répété pendant six
heures lundi mardi et jusqu'à vendredi
le cancer
donc une semaine intense où ils auront à
la fois du travail avec moi en grand
orchestre comme on a fait cet après midi
et puis du travail aussi par plus petits
groupes avec des jeunes futurs
professionnels qui vont venir les
encadrer pendant des petites séances
pour pour aller faire du travail un
petit peu plus de détails et dès le
premier jour de stage vous attaquiez
dans un écrin de théâtre montansier de
140 ans d'histoire pas sûr que sur scène
les âges confondus arrive à cette date
là c'est aussi un bel environnement qui
peut donner motivé aussi c'est une
double chance pour nous parce que c'est
effectivement une chance d'être dans
cette ce théâtre absolument splendide
qu'il ya une histoire qui est vraiment
un des bijoux de nos théâtres français
dans lequel on fait peut-être plus de
théâtre habituellement que de queue de
concert donc on est ravis d'habiter ce
lieu aussi par la musique et c'est aussi
une chance que nous puissions bénéficier
de saint-ambroix toute la semaine
puisque pour des musiciens pour un
orchestre c'est toujours difficile de
faire des répétitions dans un lieu et de
faire des concerts dans un autre lieu ce
qui est assez souvent le cas finalement
donc là on a cette chance d'avoir ce
théâtre à notre disposition toute la
semaine c'est vraiment un grand bonheur
et un bonheur pour les yeux
il reçoit plutôt du théâtre alors une
acoustique
ça oblige les élèves à écouter
différents mondes peut-être pas vraiment
puisque cela l'acoustique fonctionne
très bien pour l' orchestre
on s'entend très bien malgré le nombre
important d'élèves enfin le nombre
important de miliciens on s'entend très
bien c'est une acoustique absolument
formidable et un très agréable aussi
pour l'orchestré
et vous vous mettez en hommage le lieu
aussi parce que l'un des morceaux qui
sera jouée avait été commandée par
marguerite brunet dit la montansier
pourquoi ce choix c'est un souk est peu
connue alors c'était un choix vraiment
artistique pour faire aussi un clin
d'oeil à ce lieu j'ai cherché pendant
très longtemps
une pièce qui auraient pu être créés
dans ce théâtre et qui pouvait aussi
être jouée par par nos par nos élèves
parce qu'il faut aussi que ça puisse
être joué aussi en terme de difficulté
et je vais vous donnez pas trouvé ce qui
a été créée ici
donc ça a été un petit peu le pli le
petit clin d'oeil d'avoir cette pièce
qui avait été commandée par parra par la
montansier et de la faire vivre ici et
c'est effectivement une pièce qui
s'appelle les avancées rage qui n'est
pas du tout connu qui est très peu joué
et de cherubino qui était un grand
compositeur français du début du 19e fin
xviiie début du 19ème et voilà c'est
important de faire vivre cette musique
aussi quai de la musique française le
nom mythique et robin equallogic
française et de la faire vivre dans ce
magnifique théâtre et d'autres grands
compositeurs des 18e et 19e bizet tirer
comme ce qui beethoven sept sont des
oeuvres exigeantes ou pour lé second
cycle vous avez dû adapter
alors je n'ai absolument rien adapté
puisque c'est c'est eh mon ma volonté
pour ce stage là et de manière générale
avec les orchestres de ce niveau là
c'est de pouvoir aborder du vrai
répertoire sert pas quelque chose qui
soit arrangé pas qu'ils soient adaptés
pour les pour les pour les enfants ils
ont la capacité ils ont le niveau de
pouvoir s'attaquer à des répertoires qui
sont comme ça alors vraiment bien choisi
parce que il ya plein de choses qui se
font donc ils ont des cuiseurs des défis
qu'ils auraient des difficultés à jouer
mais voilà ça me paraît important de les
confronter vraiment surtout sur une
semaine de travail intense comme celle
ci de les confronter à du répertoire à
des grands compositeurs à des grandes
oeuvres puisque c'est de la musique qui
y apporter des des musiciens pendant des
générations et des générations que c'est
de la musique qui va les porter eux
aussi ils ont montré qu'ils peuvent tous
jouer
il y à du théâtre bizet de la danse la
valse des fleurs de tchaïkovski on l'a
tous entendu un jour alors c'était un
petit peu l'articulation de ce programme
c'est de travailler autour des musiques
de scène alors musique de scène on a
pris ça d'une manière extrêmement large
la musique de scène c'est la musique
pour qu'ils accompagnent le théâtre donc
on a la musique de l'arlésienne de bizet
qui accompagne le théâtre la musique de
scène c'est aussi la danse évidemment
avec la le tchaïkovski et la valse des
fleurs
la musique de scène c'est aussi le
cinéma aujourd'hui voilà donc on a un
petit clin d'oeil à john williams avec
une musique de du d'un des derniers star
wars et puis
voilà et puis aussi un petit peu de
méthode voilà tout un tout un programme
autour de ces musiques de scène et
c'était ça ce sera le fil conducteur de
notre de notre soirée
et justement on va terminer sur star
wars genou liane sans doute l'un des
plus grands compositeurs de musique de
films actuels dans un lieu qui a deux
cent quarante ans d'histoire c'est aussi
faire le lien avec les jeunes sur scène
oui absolument après moi je joue
personnellement je n'ai jamais à faire
ce lien parce que pour moi ce lien est
naturelle et on n'est pas un
anachronisme prêt quand on joue du
beethoven à la philharmonie ou contre
joue du john williams à montansier donc
ça pour moi c'est vraiment pas un
problème il ya des toutes les musiques
sont sont bonnes à prendre on est dans
des contextes différents on est des
propos pour le mélanger ces répertoires
là doivent vivre vraiment on n'a pas de
il n'y a pas de kodak a c'est en fait un
tout les toutes ces musiques là doit
vivre et et rentre dans le répertoire et
ça je crois que c'est aussi quelque
chose d'important que ces musiques de
films john williams et d'autres d'ennio
morricone des gens qui nient qu'ils sont
le très connu et mal gré de la musique
formidables vont aussi rentrer dans le
répertoire des orchestres sont déjà
d'ailleurs rentré dans le répertoire des
orchestres symphoniques
c'était le cas je prends toujours cet
exemple des musiques de scène qui sont
des musiques pour accompagner le théâtre
comme l'arlésienne et qui sont
maintenant rentrer dans le répertoire
des orchestres même complètement
indépendamment des pièces auxquelles
elle était rattachée
donc voilà la musique de film pour moi
aussi cette cette vocation
dans les années qui viennent merci
beaucoup quand c'est encore bri
alors le concert est à voir au théâtre
montansier vendredi 27 avril à 19h avant
de se quitter reconnecter les yvelinois
avec la nature qui les entoure c'est
l'objectif du parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse le pnr
propose des animations pour découvrir la
faune et la flore environnante
mardi dernier une équipe de petits
explorateurs dans laquelle s'est glissée
camille lambert est allé rencontrer les
habitants de la mare donc les pétales
sont arrivés vous avez un petit peu pour
lui
ce sont les stars du jour les tritons ce
petit amphibien de la famille des
salamandres se trouve dans les mares le
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse propose aux enfants d'aller
à la découverte de cet environnement et
de leurs habitants un milieu qui est
tout proche de chez eux et bien souvent
ils ne connaissent pas du tout est ce
qu'on aimerait bien conclure à la fin de
matinée cette animation c'est qu'ils se
rendent compte du foisonnement de vie
qui peut et qui peut exister dans un
dans une petite surface d'eau comme
celle ci la diversité des espèces des
déplacements de la manière de se nourrir
de la manière de chasser de la manière
de respirer
têtards larves de salamandre de
libellules ou deux cas l'opt rx d
animaux plus ou moins connus qui ont
fait sensation auprès des plus jeunes
autre vedette de la journée
la larve de 10 tic qui ressemble à une
sorte de crevettes pas à l'accueil qui
est déjà en l'air la queue fourchue est
baladé petit crochet devant je me suis
dit nafi siav est ce que je connaissais
pas son nom mais sinon ça ressemblait un
peu un scorpion se trouve à un petit
scorpion simple annen forment des
monticules et du coup on a rempli les
renseignements j'aimais go-fast
l'atelier conte apprennent des choses
quand j'ai un bug twinning un moment de
sensibilisation à la protection de la
faune et de la flore
l'animation se termine par la remise en
liberté des petites bêtes
d'autres visites en mai et engins sont
prévues pour les enfants mais aussi pour
les adultes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi à suivre ce soir sur tv 78
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat et cette
édition elle est à consulter à nouveau
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv
soixante dix huit belle soirée à tous
[Musique]